that is still one thing that we don't
know and it's about angles so we know
about probabilities whatever you give me
I can tell you what is the probability
that light gets reflected or refracted I
know the probabilities but I don't know
about angles and what we need to know is
that light rays of light slow down they
travel with the speed of light but they
slow down as they enter me because
there's atoms particles in there and
it's more difficult to get through so
light slow stuff the index of refraction
dancing by exactly how much so the index
of refraction of the medium is given by
this fraction the speed of light in
vacuum that we go over the speed of
light in this medium so this is how we
can write it up let's look at an example
the index of refraction of glass is 1.5
so we know exactly what the speed of
light inside glass is well it's 300
million meters per second in vacuum and
what we know is this equation so this is
the index of refraction so I can just
reorder this thing and conclude that
light if it travels in vacuum 200 300
million meters per second but in glass
it loses the third of its velocity and
it's only 200 million meters per second
so that's that's a pretty easy
calculation and it's pretty neat and
another absolutely beautiful thing
hopefully you have studied the Maxwell
equations and
vectors in physics light is ultimately a
wave so here above and below you can see
some wave behavior and the array is
essentially the wavefront of these waves
so light can be imagined as rays if you
take into consideration that I would
need to compute many of these wave
fronts in order to take account for the
way behavior and don't look at the rent
only look at the blue this is above this
is a vacuum and below this could be for
instance glass and you can see that the
waves slow down in this video and what
this means if we go back to the
definition of the wavefront start the
red lines then they are essentially
bending because the wave fronts are
going to look like this so it's it's
very interesting because if you imagine
light as a wave it only slows down but
if you imagine life as a ray then it
bends it changes direction so I think
that's absolutely beautiful and the
question is why is the light reflecting
in words because what I would imagine is
that it continues normally it continues
its way with this theta T equals theta I
because it would just continue its way
and it doesn't continue it's very
offensive it and the question is why and
now it we have can Academy time raise
your hand if you know can Academy okay
awesome
awesome weather well-educated people so
this is shamelessly stolen from Canada
this is the best way to describe how
refraction works so basically you
imagine that you have a large car and
the air vacuum interface is now rolled
and mud I mean the road is the air and
mud is glass for instance and imagine as
you are approaching this disbander a
line between the two then the first
wheel of the car like the lower left on
this image is entering the mount but the
other but on the other side the wheels
are still on the road
so therefore this wheel will slow down
in the mud but this is still going as
fast as it used to be so what will the
car do if this happens it will start
with turns and you know exactly when it
would turn because this is going slow
this is going faster so therefore it
will turn inwards so this is I think an
amazing interpretation of the boat I
think also it's easy to explain with the
waves because when the waves are slowed
down and they are the direction
that we can see that the circles will
get
exactly then we will exactly like in the
previous figure that's that's another
intuition that you wanted to ask if you
cessation to sukira this because I don't
feel school now this is intuition that's
why it's a good feeling it's nice this
is strictly intuition okay so if you
would if you would start tomorrow rays
of light like trucks on going you're
gonna encounter problems you could take
this part of the way if it's the medium
first and that's like oh I wouldn't
forget love is it I tend to give
multiple ways to interpret things
because you know different minds work
differently some graphical ways are
working for different people better okay
so stars law and we're almost done for
today
Snell's law tells you in what angle
refracted rays are going to continue
their path and this is given by this
expression signs of the angles against
velocities against the reciprocal of
indices of refraction okay so let's do
the air class example of the previous
image let's State our expectations
before we go so I'm interested in the
relation of theta I versus speed of T so
I know these expressions exactly how
much is Theta I am in degrees Susan is
60 okay excellent
how much is Theta the degrees
it's something around 35 exactly okay so
the light is reflected in words
therefore the theta T must be less than
the theta R so this must be less like
this let's compute the equation and see
if this works and if it doesn't work
we're going to call out the physicist
song so let's just reorder some things
and let's put there the indices of
refraction x' and the incoming light
angle that we know and just some very
simple reordering we are almost there
and if we actually compute the sine of
60 degrees we get this well this is
almost we can also carry out the
division but at this point I'm not
interested in the sine of theta T I'm
interested in theta T so I would
multiply both sides invert the equation
by multiplying with the inverse of the
sine so this theta T should be the arc
sine of this and if I compute everything
back to degrees then I will get this
entity which is 30 4.75 so whoever said
35 was very close to the actual result
but also not to forget that there are
different kinds of glasses I mean
there's there's multiple ways of
creating and and manufacturing classes
and they have different indices of
refraction more or less the same but
when it's still different but we can see
that this is this isn't in a really good
agreement with what we see in real life
well what did we say theta T should be
less than theta I but 35 is definitely
less than 60 so again physics works and
physicists are smart people and just
another example if you think about the
car example or whichever example you
like better you will hopefully
immediately see that if we would go in
with the yellow arrow this is going to
bend inwards after going back from the
river to the air now
whoa hold it right there what is
happening I don't see any reflection
whatsoever right but it seems to me that
if I go back at around how much is this
in degrees that's 50 degrees exactly so
something fishy happens that's 50
degrees well I don't know what is
happening I'll tell you the name and
we're going to compute whether this is
possible or not well if it's not
possible that our math sucks so let's
see so what we what we call this is
total internal reflection there is a
critical angle and after this critical
angle there is no more refraction
there's only there's no more refraction
only reflection happens and there is
many examples of that and there's many
applications of that this is one of the
more beautiful examples so let's compute
what's what's going on here what I know
is that I have the indices of refraction
I know I know this big this degree and
that we just dealt with and something
interesting should happen here and
something interesting already happened
so I just plugged in everything what I
have seen on this image and I get this
and this is awfully horribly terribly
wrong someone please help me out flies
them
okay yes fine can't be bigger than one
exactly so the support of the sign is
between one and minus one at least
according to my experiences so it's
saying that the sine of an angle is more
than one is mathematically not possible
so it says that there's no such angles
what would be the angle of refraction if
I would use using fifty degrees then it
says something that mathematically
doesn't make any sense
so math actually suggests to you if you
use the right numbers it suggests to you
already that this total internal
reflection would happen let's try to
compute the critical angle and this I
just reordered things this is hopefully
the critical angle that and we'll be
trying to compute well if I have this
theta 1 this is a relatively small
number that there is going to be
refraction there is this critical angle
on the second figure at which I have
this 90 degree refraction so it's a at
the critical angle this thing is going
to be 90 degrees and after that so this
is smaller than this
after this critical angle is only going
to be a reflection now let's try to
compute this note notice that 90 degrees
here so what I put here is this is what
I'm interested in and this happens when
this refraction is at 90 degrees so I
put there it's 90 degrees explicitly and
I want to know this theorem it's going
to be that that's going to be the
critical angle what if I actually
do a computation with a 90 degrees that
I'm going to get one for the sign so
this is n2 over n1 well I'm still not
interested in the sine of this angle I'm
interested in their angle so I have to
invert the other side both sides of the
equation and this is the definition of
the critical angle and if you write it
in Wikipedia critical angle you are
going to get the very same formula but
the most interesting thing is that you
can actually derive this yourself and
this is not the huge derivation this is
very simple this is where this 90 degree
refraction happens so what is our
expectation for this critical angle
let's look at the reality again what so
this is I'm just trying to hint without
saying telling you the solution so let's
try it without hints what what could be
the critical angle here raise your hand
if you know the answer okay sorry height
ideal for pedagogical reason I will ask
someone where I haven't asked before
okay let's see if it's correct
I have a cm I asked you before nothing
important
nothing important okay now you get it in
for my question it should be something
smaller than 50 degrees because $10 over
exactly source also the usual answer
what I get is that 50 degrees because I
see total internal reflection but total
internal reflection means that after Sun
at some point after that is only going
to be
to action so it doesn't mean that if it
doesn't mean that this is that point
because if I would be trying 60 degrees
I will also see reflection but this
doesn't mean that 60 degrees is the
critical angle it's before that at some
point okay what is your answer okay what
is your answer oh yes but always
thinking that if it's if it's critical
than you for example say 50 is pretty mm
then we would have also reflection and
then a horizontal one is again yes what
what you have seen on the figure so at
the critical angle you see this instead
of this
so this is over the critical angle so it
has to be less than 50 degrees less than
650 degrees okay so this is very simple
from here let's just substitute the
indices of refraction for T 1.81
wonderful physics works and we are still
alive so that's basically it for today
we have used reality to be our judge we
are not just writing formulae on paper
and then be happy about how much we can
understand or how much we can memorize
of them we put everything to use and you
will see all of this in C++ code not so
long from top so that would be the
introductory course and I'll see you
next week thank you